el índice de precios al consumidor ipc
se utiliza para medir el costo de una
canasta básica de bienes una familia
promedio en el país de jackson ya compra
cuatro piezas de pan tres kilos de queso
crema y ocho libros cada semana los
precios de estos bienes en los años 2015
2016 y 2017 se indican en la tabla
siguiente luego se nos pide en algunas
cosas calcula el ipc en el 2017 tomando
el 2016 como año base calcula el ipc en
el 2015 tomando el 2016 como año base
calcula la tasa de inflación entre el
2015 y el 2016 calcula la tasa de
inflación entre el 2016 y el 2017
describe la razón por la cual la tasa de
inflación entre el 2016 y el 2017 podría
exagerar los cambios en el costo de vida
pausa el vídeo y trata de resolver esto
tú solo antes de que lo hagamos juntos
muy bien ahora vamos a resolverlo paso a
paso
en las dos primeras preguntas se nos
pide calcular el ipc en el 2017 y en el
2015 tomando el 2016 como año base para
hacerlo vamos a colocar una nueva
columna aquí
este es el costo de la canasta semanal y
nos van a indicar cuánto se compra cada
semana veamos en el 2015 se compran 4
piezas de pan a un peso cada una
entonces tenemos 4 por 1 también se
compran 3 kilos de queso crema a 3 pesos
el kilo entonces ponemos 3 por 3 además
a esta gente le gusta leer y compra 8
libros cada semana en el 2015 cada libro
cuesta 10 pesos entonces vamos a poner 8
por 10 esto va a ser 4 por 1 igual a 4 +
9 es igual a 13 más 80 es igual a 93
pesos ahora vamos a calcular esa misma
canasta semanal en el 2016 otra vez se
compran 4 piezas de pan pero ahora cada
una cuesta 2 pesos entonces ponemos 4
por 2 también se compran 3 kilos de
queso crema ahora a 6 pesos el kilo
entonces va a ser más 3 por 6 más 8
libros cada semana a 20 pesos cada libro
es 8 por 20 esto va a ser igual a 8 18
que es 26 más 160 lo cual nos da 186
entonces aquí vamos a poner 186 pesos
ahora vamos a hacer el mismo cálculo
para el 2017
cada semana se compran 4 piezas de pan
pero ahora cada una cuesta 3 pesos
además se compran 3 kilos de queso crema
y cada kilo todavía cuesta 6 pesos más 8
libros cada semana a 25 pesos cada libro
esto va a ser igual a 12 más 18 que es
30 más 200 lo cual nos va a dar 230
pesos ya podemos calcular los ipcs por
lo general el ipc del año base va a ser
100 así que lo ponemos así aquí para los
otros años el ipc va a ser el costo de
la canasta en ese año dividido entre el
costo del año base por 100 obviamente
para el 2016 va a ser el costo en el
entre el costo en el 2016 y multiplicado
por 100
el resultado es 100 pero para el 2015 va
a ser el costo de la canasta en el 2015
el cual es 93 pesos dividido entre el
costo en el 2016 que es 186 pesos por
100 de hecho este cálculo es bastante
sencillo 93 es la mitad de 186 así que
va a ser igual a 0.5 por cien es igual a
50 para el 2017 va a ser el costo de la
canasta en el 2017 dividido entre el
costo de la canasta en el 2016 y
multiplicado por 100 usemos nuestra
calculadora para hacer esta operación
230 dividido entre 186 es igual a
aproximadamente 1 punto 24 si lo
multiplicamos por 100
el resultado será aproximadamente 124
entonces calcula el ipc en el 2017
tomando el 2016 como año base el
resultado es 124
calcula el ipc en el 2015 tomando el
2016 como año base el resultado es 50
calcula la tasa de inflación entre el
2015 y el 2016 esto es cuánto aumentaron
los precios si tomamos esta canasta de
bienes en el 2015 y en el 2016 bueno
podemos ver que el ipc pasó de 50 a 100
entonces los precios se duplicaron
cuando algo se duplica aumenta en un 100
por ciento y la tasa de inflación es el
aumento de los precios entonces aquí
tenemos una inflación del 100% los
precios de los productos se duplicaron y
puedes verlo aquí aquí todos los precios
se duplicaron ahora calcula la tasa de
inflación entre el 2016 y el 2017 pues
bien si el ipc estaba en 100 y aumentó a
124 hubo un aumento del 24% otra manera
de visualizarlo es multiplicar 100 por
1.24 lo cual es lo mismo que un aumento
del 24%
entonces ese aumento del 24 por ciento
es la tasa de inflación describe la
razón por la cual la tasa de inflación
entre el 2016 y el 2017 lo que acabamos
de calcular aquí en la pregunta de
podría exagerar los cambios en el costo
de vida
si todavía no respondes esta parte te
recomiendo poner en pausa el vídeo
examina todo lo que hemos hecho y trata
de llegar a una respuesta muy bien
veamos lo que ocurrió del 2016 al 2017
el precio de cada pieza de pan aumentó
en un 50% el precio de cada libro
aumentó 5 pesos sobre una base de 20 ese
es un incremento del 25% sin embargo el
precio del queso crema no cambió
esto es más 0% porque no experimentó
ninguna inflación entre el 2016 y el
2017 ahora imagina un escenario en el
que los precios de algunos bienes
aumentan mucho mientras que otros no la
canasta de bienes podría cambiar la
gente podría comprar menos pan y libros
y más
queso crema entonces podemos decir que
en la canasta básica
podrían tener más peso los bienes con
menos cambios en sus precios
por ejemplo en este caso el queso crema
porque parecen relativamente más baratos
que los bienes con más inflación
si esto ocurriera tendríamos un menor
crecimiento real del costo de vida
en realidad esta última pregunta se
refiere al hecho de que el ipc no es
necesariamente un indicador perfecto
porque dado que los distintos bienes de
la canasta tienen diferentes tasas de
inflación en sus precios puede haber un
efecto de sustitución entre los
distintos bienes ahora bien cada país
trata de volver a equilibrar la canasta
de bienes tomando como base su
percepción de lo que es típico o se le
atribuye más valor a cierto tipo de
bienes como una especie de promedio
ponderado pero repito una vez más que
eso no necesariamente va a ser perfecto
hasta el próximo vídeo